Listing out the prime factorizations, we can see that our greatest common factor
is 8ab squared. So this is what I list on the outside of a parenthesis to start
the factor. We're left with 5ab for the first term. If I factor 8 times ab
squared out of the first term, I'm left with 5 times ab. That goes here.
Negative 2b squared would be remaining from the second term. And negative 3
would be remaining for this last term. Essentially, we're just dividing this
term by 8ab squared. We know ab squared divided by ab squared would equal one,
so we're just left with negative 24 divided by 8, which is negative 3. As
always, you can check your result by multiplying or distributing this 8ab
squared to each of the terms. You should wind up with your original expression.